all right let's check out this 3m cup
mask you know is it legit or is it not
let's find out this is an n95 mask the
same type the biden administration has
begun distributing for free oh the
concentration is coming way down here so
that's a that's a really good sign
n95 is a type of respirator mask kn-95
is another it's very comfortable i have
a good fit here properly fitted masks
like these can provide better protection
from the particles that carry coved if
everybody was wearing a respirator
during a surge you would stun
transmission because you have two-way
protection approaching 95 percent that's
95 percent of particles blocked from
being inhaled and exhaled too thus the
95 of the names but that's only when
these respirator masks perform properly
i want to make sure i get a good seal on
it problem is it's tough to know if your
mask actually has 95 filtration
efficiency a search on amazon where
masks have been a top search term
through the pandemic turns up thousands
of results and underperforming masks can
creep in and notice that concentration
coming down but not as low as i'd like
to see it
so what can you do to find a good mask
and how easy is it to accidentally get a
bad one
to find out we bought some popular maths
on amazon and put them to the test with
experts that's that difference between
there and there is the sign of a good
mask or a fake mask this is aaron
collins also known as the mask nerd so
these are my collection of masks i feel
like i have every mass that you might be
able to get from south korea or in the
united states right now collins is a
mechanical engineer with a background in
aerosol science he says spotting poor
performing masks is tough because they
can look identical to the good ones that
is the real crux of the problem is you
can have a good mask or have a bad mask
and you won't know his solution testing
masks live on youtube from his home lab
which is his bathroom if you just are
given a mask and you don't know anything
about mask you're gonna think wow i got
99 95 protection
so we asked collins to do the same for
us with the three n95s and the five
kn95s we ordered from amazon all of the
kn95s were listed as top 10 best sellers
and one of the n95s was labeled as an
amazon choice at the time of purchase
the n95s we ordered all received
certification from the national
institute for occupational safety and
health or niosh we boxed up samples of
the eight mast and sent them off to
collins for testing the test that i do
is what's uh called a total inward
leakage test what you need for this type
of measurement is two things you need an
aerosol source and a particle counter
without getting too technical collins
uses these two machines to test the
filtration efficiency of the masks to
show how they perform as he wears them
the results appear on his laptop as he
tests
basically the more this line falls the
better the mask is at filtering outside
aerosols
one thing you'll notice right away is
that that concentration has now dropped
way down this indicates that it's very
likely a legitimate mask
for his test collins is looking for the
highest filtration percentage possible
he says n95s and kn95s typically reach
about 97 or higher
of the eight masks we sent him six
performed well the one that was labeled
amazon choice this 3m and 95 reached
99.7
all right well 3m ones that i got
definitely real but two of the masks we
sent did not reach the filtration
efficiency collins typically sees oh
not looking good this one a kn 95
labeled wanway marked as an amazon best
seller yeah 88
that there my friends
is most likely a very underperforming kf
okay at 95 sorry
and this one i'm doubtful a niosh
approved n95 mask from aeropro which
came in at 92.5 percent in collins test
i'm not convinced that this is real
either that's pretty low performing so
after getting these results the journal
sent both underperforming masks as well
as the 3m and 95 that tested well to 4c
air a lab that performs the tests
required for mass to receive niosh
approval
five samples of each mask were tested
all five 3m masks tested with a
filtration efficiency above 99 percent
which 4c air set is in line with most
n95s it tests but only one of the
aeropro masks met the 95 threshold the
rest fell short with the mask averaging
just over 93 filtration efficiency the
lab said this indicates this batch would
likely not earn niosh approval as none
can fall below 95 percent niosh said it
can't comment on the results as the
testing was not done in its lab
all of the masts labeled want wayne
vastly underperformed averaging 81.9
percent with the lowest filtration
efficiency at 77.5
based on these tests 4c air said this
mask would fall short of the can 95
standard both aeropro and the company
that sells the wan wayne labeled masks
did not respond to multiple requests for
comment in a statement amazon said we
take credible allegations of
non-compliance seriously conduct
internal investigations and hold bad
actors accountable for violating amazon
rules and policies after the journal
reached out to amazon for comment the
aeropro mask listing had been removed
and after the journal shared the test
results with amazon the wan wayne mask
was still available for purchase the
white version was listed as an amazon
choice
so are these masks fake that's tough to
say there's still masks that filter
particles but not at the 95 filtration
efficiency required by the n95 and kn95
standards
and that leaves wearers less protected
than they think
so what can you do if you have a bad
mask
well you can try opening one up let's go
ahead and take a look in here so the
filtration layer is this layer here this
is the melt blown electrostatically
charged polymer layer it's polypropylene
while the exact number of layers in a
respirator mask may differ the one to
look for is this filter layer aka the
melt blown electrostatically charged
polymer layer and you can see there's
you can sort of pull that apart and see
the sort of intricate design that goes
into a filter it's that filter that
traps the smallest aerosol particles the
kind that can carry the virus
but seeing the filter isn't enough to
know for sure that it's a legit mask
either the aeropro and the wayne
labelled masks for example both had
filtration collins says there are other
clues you can look for to spot a
possibly poor mask starting with the
labeling on the outside they got most of
the canon 95 standard requirements
although they did not get
the manufacturer name on there make sure
the mask is trying to at least meet some
of the standard requirement there are
labeling requirements as part of the can
95 standard kn95s should say kn95 they
should also say gb 2626-2006
or 2019. lastly they should say the
manufacturer's name if you just see the
kn95 stamp on there you already know
that that mask doesn't meet the
requirements of the kn-95 standard so
what else does it not meet none of the
can 95 masks we tested even the high
performing ones had all of this
information on the mask and that colin
said adds confusion for consumers
the centers for disease control and
prevention keeps a list of known
counterfeit km95s or those
misrepresenting niosh approval the n95
labeling requirements are much more
stringent for these masks they also need
to say n95 they need to have the niosh
logo or text on there as well as the
approval number starting with t and c
they also must have the manufacturer's
name you can use the information printed
on the mask to verify its niosh approval
against the list on the cdc's website
still that isn't foolproof either the
aeropro n95 met these labeling
requirements and appeared on the niosh
approval list for example
here collins has another tip check the
supplier if you're buying from a big box
retailer or you're buying from the
manufacturer's website or through their
amazon web server so if you go to like
3m's direct site the probability of
getting a fake i think is really much
lower because of that niosh requirement
and the regulation that happens around
it in the case of the aeropro mask the
seller was accunet a medical supply
company that also sells third-party
masks in a statement accumed said that
as a distributor of niosh n95
respirators we place our trust in the
cdc niosh and the fda to validate the
manufacturers listed on their websites
as approved accumed said it also plans
to start independently testing the mass
itself it no longer sells the aeropro
mask the journal purchased niosh said it
will add the aeropro mask to the list of
the products it plans to audit this year
i think it gets much harder to be
trusting of the brands without some
piece of third-party evidence that the
mass that they're supplying is good and
i don't see that on amazon listings i
don't see a third party that has tested
the mask and said this is the results
amazon said it has a rigorous seller
vetting and product review process for
n95 and kn95s that involves comparing
masks against the cdc's counterfeit mask
list and the niosh approval list as well
as obtaining test results from an
accredited lab in china for kn95 masks
when it comes to third-party sellers
collin suggests project n95 a non-profit
that only sells masks it is vetted or
there's one other option and that's not
to shop at all the biden administration
has started distributing 400 million
n95s to pharmacies and community health
centers across the country the mass are
free and limited to three per customer
i'll be honest i wish this happened in
january 2021 but it's better late than
never we we will deal with more variance
we'll deal with more epidemic surges in
the future and
the bar has now been raised the bar has
been raised to n95 mask this is
critically important
[Music]